élément nouveau c'est quand il ya eu
cette unification technico économique
après l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique c'est à dire que le marché le
capitalisme se sont introduits par tous
à seulement dans la rue cible y compris
en chine où s'est créé une alliance tout
à fait étonnante entre la dictature d'un
parti totalitaire et disons le
développement du profit capitaliste
donc il ya eu cette unification au même
moment grâce à internet grâce à interpol
grâce à tours on communique de tous les
coins du monde et malgré ce fait que ya
cette unification technique et
communicationnel on se comprend de moins
en moins les yougoslaves se sont
désintégrées à ce moment là justement
les laits l'est et dans le fossé
c'est ça la halle le point essentiel ça
a créé une interdépendance s'ancrer la
solidarité et en créant souvent au
contraire der fermeture sur soi sur sa
culture compense menacé par
l'occidentalisation qui s'éteint donc
voilà le grand problème il faut repenser
la globalisation il faut repenser la
politique économique fondée sur le
néolibéralisme depuis madame thatcher et
monsieur reggane et que tout ceci
aujourd'hui ve fait déjà et balayez
c'était extraordinaire de voir que
aujourd'hui 2 après que partout que
l'europe ait poussé pendant des années à
diminuer les crédits dépôts les hôpitaux
et pour que des hôpitaux le guen comme
des entreprises commerciales privées
faisant des bénéfices à partir on a vu
maintenant le désastre de cette
politique
on le voit dans les services publics
sont vitaux les le rôle de l'état et est
capital ce qui n'empêche pas de pouvoir
coopérer et les autres états il ya une
repenser total de la politique
qui est nécessaire
[Musique]